hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round 11 of the
feeder candidates tournament it's
fabiano corona versus dingler and both
of them now as you know former members
of the 2800 club and um
whenever i talk about the the clashes
between these two gentlemen i always say
how they are one of the most exciting
games the the most complicated games and
that it's just impossible to calculate
everything that um
happens when when fabian didn't play so
this game is no exception you guys will
enjoy it let's dive straight into it and
then we're going to discuss about uh
what this means for the standing so
before we check it out uh here is a nice
photo of the two of them uh i like it
that it's uh from the si it's not from
the actual side where the photographers
usually stand it's from the other side
uh so you don't have all the corporate
logos as i know you guys really hate
those and you can see the the playing
call and everything and you know just
the the general setting you see there
they are avoiding eye contact just you
know ready for the fight to begin
and i don't know i i really like ding's
uh
shirt collar i think it's uh it suits
him very well it was a definitely for
former not a former 2800 player he's a
he's even a current 2800 player uh but
yeah that's uh what we get from the
photo and now it's uh fabi to move he
opens with ponte e4
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 going for the royal opus
and now a6 going for the uh morphy's
defense bishop to a4 we have knight to
f6 and castles bishop to e7 and rook to
e1 so
by now you're probably already wondering
will we finally see the marshall attack
the pawn to b5 attacks the bishop bishop
to b3 and now castles and this is the
legendary position where if white plays
c3 uh there is no player in the world
that does not play d5 martial attack
will definitely happen however fabi goes
for the anti-martial variation and he
plays a4 so there are that that's one of
the popular ways to decline the marshall
the other the the other you can push the
h pawn uh but uh we will not be seeing
c3 here so here we have bishop to b7
this is the standard way to approach
this anti-martial variation d3 d6 and
now bishop to d2 with queen to d7 uh
developing the queen connecting the
rooks knight to c3 and now knight to a5
attacking the bishop here so bishop to
a2 and pawn to b4 now attacking the
knight knights the e to end pawn to c5
we have knights the g3 going after that
f5 square but just rook a to b8 so again
all been played before nothing new here
however the known ideas here are c3 and
the immediate knight to f5 but five
we've prepared something else fabi plays
knight to h4 and it is now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game and
uh it's it's a very exciting uh
position so the thing is of course the
knight uh one of the
the knights want to come to the f5
square so dean has to play g6 to prevent
this but fabi doesn't mind he plays
bishop h6 chases away the rook rook f8
and now knight h to f5 and can you grab
this uh knight well not really if you
grab the knight then knight captures on
f5 and you can't really stop queen f3
queen g3 and it's game over so the
knight for the moment cannot be captured
uh and the ding just plays bishop to d8
it's a
definitely the best move if you go
bishop to f8 which kind of seems like
you're getting rid of some of the
attackers uh fabi can play bishop g5 and
then after bishop g7 defending the
knight we just capture it and after
bishop captures now knight h5 and this
is definitely uh all uh within uh fabi's
um preparation uh so if ding win for
this it would be bad news you're
threatening knight captures here this
just wins the game if you capture then
again queen gets access to all of the
attacking squares and if you move the
bishop then we give a check and now we
pick up the f7 punk king a fade bishop
captures an f7 again i hope you did not
forget our about our good friend the
light square bishop and uh well against
fabio pretty much resigned this so uh
ding plays bishop to d8 a very important
defensive move as you'll see later on uh
knight the g7 by fabi attacking the rook
and now rook back to f8 and here uh you
could we we could just see a repetition
but fabi of course uh he
uh did not have the greatest of time in
the last three games that he played in
the last three games fabi lost two games
and drew one so he really needs a win
but yeah you could i guess repeat here
rook 8 we just repeat 97 rook f8 and
it's a draw by repetition but fabi plays
h3 first and now pawn to b3 now dink
closes this diagonal and he says no uh
no no repetitions for you so okay bishop
captures on b3 you could also capture
with the pawn but uh it's not uh
it's not all that impressive the knight
will come to c6 then to b4 then go after
the bishop uh this way at least you grab
a pawn so bishop captures uh on b3
knight captures pawn captures and the
bishop the c6 now
uh going after the the b3 pawn if the
white queen moves we have rook to c1 and
now king the h8
now preparing knight to g8 to kick away
the bishop from the h8 square h6 square
and now ding has to go for it knight to
e6 he attacks the rook here uh and the
plays queen captures an e6 and this is
in fact the the absolute strongest way
to refute the idea uh because of what
happens next so queen captures on e6
fabi grabs the rook on f8 but now bishop
to a5 attacks the rook and attacks the
bishop on f8 so it's better to give up
the exchange than a piece bishop back to
h6 bishop captures any one queen
captures and now just rook captures on
b3 uh we have queen to a5 by fabi going
after the a6 pawn and not knight g8
kicking away the bishop bishop to e3 and
the bishop to b7 and now you have this
position where after all of this madness
it's a it's a dead equal material now
the only thing that's different is that
the bishops are of opposite color but
other than that it's equal material no
no doubled pawns no uh imbalances in the
position so this is one one uh hell of a
game so here queen back to d2 by fabi
now pawn to f6 just improving the uh the
position we have f4 by fabi and now e
captures an f4 bishop captures g5 pushes
away the bishop bishop to e3 and now
queen to e5 attacking the knight here so
knight to f5 it's an excellent square
for the knight and not knight to e7
offering a trade of knights fabi goes
for it knight captures queen captures
and now queen to c2 attacking the rook
rook to b6 and now rook back to f1 so
now fabi wants to organize an attack
against the dean's king he's putting
pressure on the f file he wants the rim
maneuver to bishop over to c3 to grab
hold of this diagonal and then it's only
a matter of uh
well fully activating the queen and
sorry about that and um as as we still
have bishops of opposite colors uh of
course you know that uh once that this
dark square bishop starts attacking the
light square bishop cannot oppose it and
of course it works the other way around
if this bishop becomes super active then
the dark square bishop is useless in uh
helping
out with the defense so here king the g7
uh
i actually guessed the the move
correctly sorry about that
now a5 chasing the rook away uh rook to
c6 and now bishop to d2 we are bringing
the bishop over to this diagonal rook
the c8 by being bishop to c3 and rook to
f8 we have to set up a defense here uh
as the f6 pawn is is attacked so queen
to f2 adding another attacker but it's
not a problem we are defending it three
times and now h6 we have h4 if i be
trying to open up the position a little
bit bishop the c8 ding has to figure out
how to activate his light square bishop
pawn to b4 now as you know you can break
through here but you can open up the b
file and then maybe bring your rook uh
well somewhere on the queen side to try
and infiltrate this way so bishop to d7
b captures on c5 d captures and now rook
to b1
we have bishop to b5 not allowing this
uh
infiltrating move with the rook and now
h captures on g5 h captures end queen to
f5 so putting more and more pressure now
the threat is queen captures on g5 as
the the f6 pawn will not be able to
capture back so king to g8 by ding and
now pawn to d4 fabi just keeps pushing
forward because uh well there's just
nothing for for him backwards uh bishop
to d3 now attacking the rook and the e4
pawn twice so rook to e1 and now c
captures on d4 we have bishop captures
on d4 and queen to h7 offering a queen
trade dingy and not yet conv
sorry fabi not yet convinced that uh
he wants to call this a day queen to f3
attacks the bishop and the bishop back
to b5 biting with e5 now uh pushing even
further and now comes queen to d7 yeah
interestingly if you play f captures on
e5 uh it's uh just a problem because
queen to d5 check and there's no good
move for you to make if rook to f7 queen
captures an e5 and this is just
impossible to defend the the dark square
uh bishop and queen battery are now too
strong rook can come to c1 rook and come
to
the c7 if needed also to the c8 if if
the rook for example moves to f8 uh so
you're not going to be able to defend
this so after this e5 move we have queen
to d7 by ding and now we have uh
bishop to c5 going after the rook here
so rook the c8 attacking the bishop and
now queen to b3 with check queen f7
blocking check and now fabi pushes the
pawn all the way to e6 creating a
beautiful pass pawn so queen to c7 and
now pawn to e7 uh seemingly uh seemingly
offering a bishop here but
not really for example uh
uh
because it it's
check from the queen so you can't
capture the bishop on c5 so king to g7
and now bishop to d4 uh putting pressure
again on this f6 pawn and the pawn is
nicely defended so how can being uh
how can being play this well queen to f4
and now he wants to bring the bishop to
c6 put pressure on this pawn uh put the
rook on h8 put the queen on h4 and then
go for some checkmating ideas here uh so
here we have uh
bishop back to e3 attacking the queen
queen to e3 is the safest move you want
to trade queens here and then just call
it a day
but fabi still wants to try bishop to e3
he attacks the queen but now he allows
this very very annoying queen the g3
move attacking the rook uh also you
can't really move the bishop because the
queen on b3 hangs so what can you play
here well queen to b4 we have to move
the queen and the defender rook here
but now rook to h8 you could also go for
bishop to c6 first attack the g2 pawn
and then only uh
when the queen defends the pawn then we
try to bring the rook over to h8 but
ding goes for it right away we have rook
to h8 and now comes e8 queen by fabi uh
the reason uh you give uh give up this
pawn is because there really isn't a
move you can make here it's
such an ugly position and you have to be
careful if you play something like
bishop f2 you might even get a mating
one as the light square bishop is
covering the f1 square so there really
isn't a move you can play here so e8
bringing a queen into the game queen to
h2 with check king f2 and now rook
captures an e8
and now comes queen to g4
uh the problem is uh if you go for uh
queen to g4 then ding has all sorts of
moves ready uh the last chance for fabi
was bishop captures on g5 this is giving
up a piece but it kind of forces a draw
because after let's say rook captures
queen captures and f captures on g5 you
will get some sort of a perpetual here
it's going to be impossible to
avoid all the checks uh but okay uh here
we have queen to g4 and now we have
queen to e5 biting and now uh you don't
have all that many tricks here now you
can't even give up the bishop or
anything uh as the e1 square will be uh
under fire from the rook and the queen
so here we have queen to d4 offering a
queen trade the problem is even if you
play something like bishop d2 to guard
the rook a queen c5 check is just deadly
uh
you don't have a good square for the
king you have to go up the board and
after king g3 let's say queen d6 check
picks up the bishop so you have to be
very very careful here so queen to d4
basically a forced queen trade and now
queen to f5 with check king to g1 and
now king to g6 being kept keeps the
queens on the board uh and improves the
position of of the king we have queen to
d2 and now bishop to c6 putting pressure
on this g2 pawn bishop to f2 now
offering a rook trade and queen to g4
now just threatening checkmate so you
have to be very careful again not to
play something like this uh so queen to
d3 with check bishop to e4 now attacking
the queen and queen to g3 again offering
a queen trade uh but now ding happily
accepts it um
as
his position is better here it's not uh
it's not yet all that
winningly clear
but if you go back for example queen e6
fob you can just play queen to c3 and
then you know
it continues we can even try and repeat
this uh so instead ding traits here we
have bishop captures on g3 and now pawn
to f5 very scary uh pushing those pawns
in front of fabi's king
bishop the c7 and now king the h5 king
f2 we have king to g4 and now rook the
c1 we have rooked the e7 by ding putting
pressure on the bishop and just rook to
c3 and here we have rook to d7 uh also
very interesting is just bishop to d3
but it's uh it's an incredibly
complicated move of course you never
want to trade here and if bishop d6 for
example you attack the rook then we go
after this e2 uh e to check and then the
the king is in trouble you don't really
have all that many good squares uh if
you're blinking to g1 we just play rook
to d2 and now there is not all that much
you can do bishop is coming to e4 and
you you're not going to be able to
defend everything so that's one of the
ways you can do it uh dinga tries the
other way he plays rook to d7 and now
fob plays g3 that's why it was a little
bit better because the pawn here was it
was a target
and and now it no longer is however
bishop to d3 by ding bishop to b8 and
now bishop to b5 and here it seems that
fabi thought it was just going to be a
repetition of moves uh he played bishop
back to c7 a move like rook to c2 keeps
fobby in the game but after bishop the
c7 which seems like
an attempt at a repetition uh it
actually completely blunders the game
for fabi uh but it's not you know
completely uh
easy to spot why however feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
ding while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that uh
fabi cannot defend against both threats
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is rook to e7 that's
the good stuff and now uh there is no
defense against the both rook to e to
check and rook captures on c7 and you
can't defend against both uh for example
if rook the c2 simply preventing rookie
do check we're gonna play bishop to d3
and now where do you move the rook uh if
you move it somewhere weird we're just
gonna capture the bishop and if you play
well there's no good move you can play
if
you're going to have to play something
like this if you don't want to allow
rook to e2 so here rook d2 rook captures
on c7 we go for a trade and it seems
like okay you're just down upon but
there's a rook c2 check king f1 and now
rook to a2 going after the a5 pawn and
you can't really defend against
everything here you have to keep an eye
on this pawn and you have to keep an eye
on this pawn you could try rook d5
though now trying to
maybe if king captures go after this
pawn but still just f4 it's it's a very
very easily winning position the king is
coming the pawn is coming and that's
just the game
uh so uh that's one way to do it the
other way uh well there's there's just
no good other way the other way is
bishop to d8 the one that fabi tried uh
but even this um i will not do now the
e2 square is uh is free for uh the rook
to occupy we have rook to e2 check king
to g1 not going uh for uh you know uh
for some nasty discoveries here and now
rook to d2 and that there is no way to
stop bishop d3 bishop to e4 and you will
either get checkmated or you will suffer
severe material loss bishop to e7 was
played knock on his bishop to d3 and he
was in this position unmoved 78 that
fabiano corwana resigned the game and a
very very tough uh second half of the
tournament for fabi who was co-leading
with yanni pognish in the first half of
the tournament but now out of the out of
the last four games fabi lost three
games and uh only got one draw against
the yaniponishi which is uh
uh i i don't think fabi ever had such a
such a losing streak it's just
incredible for him whereas ding i
believe gets his third victory in a row
i will check if it's in a row just you
know not to trick you guys uh but yeah
after all of these draws yeah this is
his third victory in a row he defeated
duda rapper and now caruana uh
incredibly incredible stuff two
victories with the black pieces in a row
uh incredible and uh of course you
resigned here because after you make a
move let's say bishop to d6 you have to
play something we're gonna play king to
h3 uh okay now you're defending the pawn
but what now rook the c1 you have to
play something rook to g to check
there's even this king h1 bishop to e4
and here you resign there's nothing you
can do uh whatever you play rook
captures on g3 will be checkmate uh for
as the bishop will deliver checkmate and
if you try something like uh well
there's just nothing good you can try
here play rook you want to try and give
up the rook for the bishop just bishop
f3 and if rook to e3 now we just capture
on g3 deliver check and the only move is
to give up the rook captures captures
and that's it of course the position is
completely winning so yeah after bishop
to d3 favi resigns and a brutal brutal
victory for um being liran uh
here are the
standings after after round 11 so you
guys uh are are informed of what's
happening uh nepo is still leading the
tournament with quite a convincing lead
eight points out of 11. that's that's
incredible i mean three more games until
the the end of the candidates tournament
and nip was just crushing it with eight
out of eleven and now after winning
three games in a row in second place
dingleroon with six and a half points
still uh a full point and a half behind
yanipanishi he carved with six and fabi
now only with five and a half two a
whole two and a half points behind
nipple rachel with five duda with four
and a half her upper to four and a half
and ali rezafiruja with four points and
um
nippo still needs to face uh i believe
uh he still needs to needs to face duda
he needs to face rapport and he needs to
face hikaru uh so uh it's not gonna be
easy to take him down if hikaru by some
chance wins against the nippon issue
which is definitely a possibility uh
then ding will have real chances of
winning the candidates tournament but if
hikaru doesn't beat ding uh it's uh well
it's gonna be uh
uh uh
nipple all the way i believe uh so yeah
and uh just so i don't forget here you
have a very nice photo of ding after the
game he's just enjoying the view
obviously somewhere maybe in the hall
maybe already pondering on the next game
that he's going to play uh
uh
is there a chance for him to win the
candidates tournament uh it's no longer
you know up to him if nipple just
continues playing brilliantly then
there's nothing he can do but you know
if he uh he got three wins in a row if
he can get three more wins in a row then
he might get very very close to actually
winning the candidates uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoy it tough
break for fabi uh definitely a terrible
second half of the candidates tournament
but what are you going to do
uh so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to nashi and uh i
would like to thank clever piggy odl and
ferdi forever and michael hopes
consulting and alan chevalier moore for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes and we
finally have a challenger to magnus
carlsen or or maybe to someone else uh
see you soon